was i supposed to be talking to the
camera this whole time no no you can
talk to me and the camera and hank nice
thing yes the nice thing about hi hank i
just want to meet hank though i haven't
met hank i know so i'm excited that this
video somehow involves him yeah he'll
see it awesome other people might too oh
that part scares me i'm scared about the
comments you know oh you know i'm a
little scared about this
i don't want to over hype them but in
general our people are nice i wouldn't
be able to do this video if you didn't
have such great fans because i would be
too scared of the wrath of the comments
good morning hank it's tuesday i am
joined by hannah marks the director of
the turtles all the way down movie and
thank you hannah for directing this
movie you'd only made one movie when
when you first interviewed to be the
director hannah came in
to this meeting with these producers and
studio people and she showed us what a
thought spiral would look and feel like
and it was incredible i feel like that
was the first thing that you and i
really agreed on which was that her
brain is the conflict of this movie
which we've really never seen before and
it's such a hard thing to tackle because
it's invisible right it's not tangible
so so we talked about me directing you
yesterday oh god so hannah what was it
like directing me
john green
the world's worst actor it was bliss
total bliss
and joy he was terrific he needs to stop
saying that he's a terrible actor he's a
great actor spoiler he does squats in
the movie he literally smells i don't do
i mean i better not do squats in the
movie i did squats in one take oh that
as a joke for you no that's going to be
in the final cut actually i can't
guarantee if it'll be in the final right
it will be in the director's cut well i
am gonna
i'm gonna have one note for the studio
okay
i joined tick tock just for john's
account but now you're all in you're
mostly getting dogs yeah i have almost
no dogs on my for you page well
can we even be friends then my mom has
really good advice for people yeah uh
she said uh to not marry anyone unless
they like the beetles and dogs hmm
what do you think about that
i think it's good it reminds me of an
important question though oh no do i set
myself up for the beatles question god i
mean everybody's seen it already but i
forgot the bit is there a bit who is
your favorite beatle post watching this
new documentary that came out paul
mccartney okay
so your favorite beetle used to be john
i think he was just maybe the most
famous yeah not to take away from his
talent sure he's my favorite beetle oh
great and then do you have a favorite
color green what is the beatles bit i
still don't know i think what you're
confused about is that the bit is so bad
it's that you can't believe that's the
whole bit but that is it there is no
second layer i i really like it but do
you want to know my real favorite color
yeah it's orange and you know this it's
because that is the cover of the book
has the orange spiral
and so then this is really silly but for
good luck whenever i was interviewing
for
the job for turtles i wore orange nail
polish or an orange shirt
i know that's so silly but it made me
feel better and the color palette of
this movie without giving anything away
carries some of that forward definitely
i think there's pops of orange and teal
because those are the two colors of aza
and daisy's cars which i really really
liked there are a million things that
are amazing about having you direct the
movie but one of them is that all these
little choices that we made that like
julie my editor and i made very
consciously and carefully to see those
choices loved and cared for and expanded
upon by you in all the choices that
you've made around the movie has just
been amazing oh thank you it's just
because i love the book so much i mean i
came into this being such a huge fan of
the book we gotta go we have we gotta go
we gotta oh my god we this is way too
late goodbye
say hey i'll see you on friday
me yes hank i'll see you on friday will
i actually
no
i don't know how this works